women don't feel like they need men in a
physical sense because life is soft but
it's but it's [__] and it's [__]
because you still need Men by proxy one
and two the second life gets difficult
you very quickly you very quickly learn
how much you need men but women don't go
I'm an independent I don't need no man
because I haven't only fans and men
being my only fans and if anyone comes
up to me I'll call a male police officer
I don't need men shut up [__] idiot
of course you do you just name your
whole life is based on [__] men the
roads are driving along was paved by a
man the house you're living in was built
by a man the car you're driving who was
designed by a man your whole life
depends on men and the second anything
bad were to happen to you the second you
were physically threatened or times were
to get hard or War were to start or
famine or riots the first thing you do
is find a big strong man shoot yourself
and throw the feminism out the window